I went to a school that was
predominantly black when I was growing
up and when I first saw the first white
kid I was like what is that you know
what I'm
[Music]
saying I act differently around people
who aren't my
race three two
one I think the most important thing is
just to authentically be yourself and I
don't think being around people who
don't look like you should be a reason
for you to act any different yeah for me
I guess it's like um within the confines
of
like the
workforce I was thinking code switching
because if you show up to a um a media
talking like this they're like
uneducated got it they'll use the slang
to sell the products and to tweet and to
get to clicks and stuff but like as soon
as a worker's there who's authentically
from the area
and talking like people from the area
it's like oo we don't like that you know
cuz it's always like well be yourself
until you yourself and then it's like o
I don't like yourself unfortunately in a
lot of the areas of work it's like you
you almost have to like lie to these
people to be like I'm a robot I'll like
you know I love your company you
know it's sick it's sick but it's like
you have to get you it's true like I
feel like code switching is one part but
also like there's certain parts in my
own community that aren't accepted that
when I'm around different people that
look like me I can express myself
differently like I feel like if I talk a
little proper sometimes I get a little
slack for it from my side of the family
but when I go on to the world sometimes
I like EDC I like tech music I like you
know what I'm saying see for me I feel
like it has nothing to do with race it
more has to do with just being
professional like if I'm at work then
I'm obviously going to be a little more
proper you know a little bit less slay
and all of that and just more careful
with my rhetoric but I don't think it
has to do with race the only thing I
will say is like I work in political
media so I'm on camera a lot so people
already know who I am and what I'm
coming with but that being said it's
like when I'm around other black people
because I'm a republican sometimes they
tend to be really standoffish of me or
think that I don't understand the
culture and all this different stuff so
sometimes I have to feel it out like are
these people who are just going to call
me an Uncle Tom or these people like I
can actually just keep it all the way
real with so that's the only time I feel
like I act different because of race you
know I I also work in political media
but as a leftist and I honestly feel
like I've definitely benefited from
being able to be in spaces where I've
been able to be authentically myself and
I definitely think that's a privilege
especially where I like grew up is just
like something that's regularly
happening that people have to go through
but personally I think I've been able to
especially now in a business side and
now my new workplace I feel like I don't
have to adapt my language to make people
like respect me or understand where I'm
trying to come from you know at what
point is it like damn we can't even
really have conversations without
buttoning up and being like oh this is
how we we have to talk like this cuz so
they'll listen or like regard us as but
do you think that's racial or do you
think that's just I I don't know that if
I don't know that it's because I'm right
I know where you're
going you see me we I know I know where
he going I don't think it's
intrinsically rooted in race but I think
just the way the social genetic makeup
of people are I think just by way of
people of specific races speaking a
certain way or being perceived a certain
way it just it tends to be more often
than not rooted in race based off of
like Urban black Americans yeah I think
most people have barriers they put up
when they get introduced to a new group
I went on disagree instead of strongly
disagree because like there have been
situations where I get introduced to a
group of someone of A different race and
like yeah at first I'm pulled back but
once I get comfortable with them those
walls come down and then yeah that's
where my true self comes out for me it
really uh depends because uh I've been
shooting music videos in the hood so I
really need to basically adopt myself to
become a black person so for me it's not
a problem like meeting new races I
always like Vibe and chill with people
do you think adapting yourself to those
different ethnic ethnicities is like
something that's required to um Foster
like a successful relationship like I
would say it's really more for your
survival because you know like if you
are the only white guy on like on set
and like there's like people with like
guns and stuff and you know you just
really need to like fit in and just be
chill with it mhm you're from the
Ukraine right do you feel like being
like not having grown up with American
culture as a whole and then especially
not growing up with our subcultures do
you feel like that's influenced the way
you move when you're moving between our
sub cultures my like mentality is kind
of mixed because like from the age of
like 13 I really started to to learn
English from that I really learned a lot
like I really got the American like
mentality more and basically like my
mentality is like mixed because like in
uh Ukraine if uh if we see a black
person we call them the nword mhm and
from our side it's not offensive like we
say it not from a offensive way but some
people can because you know like you
don't see a black person there I can
understand that because I went to a
school that was predominantly black when
I was growing up and when I first saw
the first white kid I was like what is
that you know what I'm saying so like it
was a white girl with like red hair and
I was like whoa I've never seen this
before you know what I'm saying so like
I understand that like when a white
person comes to a predominantly black
group then you're going to try your best
to adapt to that to our culture to be
like okay hey I get along with you this
is my way of like telling you like hey
this I'm like extending an olive branch
basically so yeah personally not to
sound triggered but I just don't like
the notion that you're becoming a black
person by pretending to be hood or
adopting a hood mentality because not
all black people are Hood not all black
people are ghetto I understand what
you're trying to say and I don't know if
it's a language barrier so I don't want
to like come at you like you're saying
something racist but I just really am
anti black people being defined as
ghetto and Hood because there's a lot of
classy black people out there yes
there's a lot of intelligent Afro
Americans out there and it really like
depends on like where you grew up in
also if you are hood and ghetto like me
you can also be all those things too
white people also experience race-based
Prejudice since you guys probably don't
know I have lived overseas I've lived in
Asian countries in Japan um there are
certain restaurants and stuff like that
that you could walk into you can see
people dining in the restaurant and
they're going to tell you they're closed
just because you're white or you're
American so the idea that white people
can't really experience racism kind of
contradicts the very definition of the
word um because the definition of racism
is Prejudice based on one skin color
white people do experience it but to a
different degree while I do think that
our White Brothers and Sisters in Christ
can experience
racial based Prejudice I don't want to
overlook the Nuance of that prejudice
because it's not necessarily rooted in
anything systematic or anything that's
going to actually have long-term effects
knock on wood that are going to like
debilitate a race or or inhibit their
chances or possibility of succeeding or
being seen as better than POC I
definitely think it's a non-issue racism
towards right people especially
specifically I want to like in America I
don't think it's something that needs to
be highlighted as an issue that is a
constant threat to lives day-to-day
well-being progress and success in life
in general CU it's not something that's
going to inhibit you and you don't have
to walk out your door and think I'm
about to be attacked like people of
color do every single day I do agree
that white people haven't been put
through centuries of hell like black
people were but Prejudice towards white
people 100% exist like whether it's in
TV if it's in movies like if you watch
predominantly black media there's a lot
of roasting towards white people that if
it was the other way around that would
never be acceptable today then you go on
social media like Tik Tok and you look
up white people are bad you will see
videos where they attacking white people
for things that their ancestors did 200
years ago there are societal benefits at
this point for being a person of color
and that those negatively affect white
people like if you look at affirmative
action diversity quotas in the workplace
all these different things they lower
the bar for black people but then
increase the bar for white people
however I think where some of the issue
comes is because a lot of margin alized
groups and people of color back in the
day went through so much worse that it's
easy for us to discredit the Prejudice
that white people now deal with today I
think like on an individualistic level
like yeah white people get hate all the
time but I think if you zoom out and you
look at the big picture it's a little
bit different and like talking about
like YouTube having you know racist
content for anyone out there it's like I
would have to go and seek that out
versus it like coming to me versus like
on Twitter against white people
yeah I would have to like look for a
video being like Oh people who hate
white people I agree like versus like
Twitter I don't have to scroll very long
before I see some person making some out
of pocket comment about and regulation
being lifted so people can see that even
more so absolutely that's 100% right and
even saying affirmative action
statistically and on paper white people
white women were benefiting more from
affirmative action in colleges than any
other demographic so I Al I also don't
think that's fair to say but I
definitely get what you mean and again I
think it's the Prejudice is still there
though and I will say that black people
do deal with prejudice I think every
demographic deals with prejudice there
are racist people everywhere like I just
don't think systemic racism is an issue
anymore in today's society but I do
think that there are racist people out
there I think that there's a really
important distinct distinction our
language is constantly evolving and you
were talking about the definition of
racism our societal definition has
changed to include a systemic part of it
and I completely disagree with this idea
that people of color don't have systemic
things against them still because the
fact that we still have the KKK the fact
that we still have these things and they
are in positions of power as long as
that exists and as long as that's a part
of our country's like makeup right now
which it is and that's our power
structure I don't feel like you can
honestly deny systemic racism against
the black community which is why
Prejudice is so different from racism I
don't think white people can experience
racism in this country but we can
experience Prejudice based on the
societal definitions we now use being
sexually unattracted to a race is
racist I think where the line gets drawn
is when if a white male is sitting there
swiping and he's just like I don't like
black girls they're all ugly they have
too big of lips I think that's where the
line gets drawn but you can't really
help what you're attracted to like my
fiance is Mexican and it's like I like
him for who he is not how he looks I
think that we are conditioned to um be
attracted and to respond to people that
we grow grow up in around with so h
ously we grow up with people who look
like us so when you move into dating and
things like that statistically you're
going to be attracted to people that you
grew up seeing right however when you
are discrediting um a certain race for
whatever reason based off their
ethnicity meaning everybody who did
exist is existing and will exist from
that race you are not feeling anything
cute I don't control your body or your
thoughts but on one hand I'm like let's
maybe unpack that also where's my camera
to all the girls that's putting this in
their bios that's of our business stop
doing that keep that to yourself we
don't want to hear it we don't want to
hear for me I think that like we're
talking about conditioning and how we
grew up right if you go to like South
Africa for instance which within some of
our lifetimes had a
partide if you grow up in that
especially as a black person where
you're constantly being mistreated by
every single white person and your
condition to be like white person no
thank you I don't think that's racist I
agree and I obviously I'm I did not grow
up in South Africa with a par tide
however like I said nickname of my town
was clany like a lot of my interactions
growing up were incredibly racist and
I'm dating the white guy so I totally
get what you mean I don't want to
discredit black people or anyone who's
had those kind of situations cuz it's
not that they're not dating white people
it's definitely it's more like they're
cautious I think you used the perfect
word earlier is it conditioned
or I I I actually I was thinking about
it on the terms of me being a black
woman I feel like it's a lot different
when it is a black woman going into
dating someone that is not of their race
um I can tell you from my experience
with dating Hispanic men white whatever
they've only seen Jerry Springer and
Mory so it's like they have a whole
different idea of what a black woman is
like before my husband changed a lot one
of the comments made to me was he was
afraid of me going to his house with
braids in my hair because then they
would assume that I was a different kind
of girl instead of looking at me for who
I am
I have been denied access because of my
race I can go anywhere I can sit down
anywhere and I am not going to be denied
because of how I look and I would be
ignorant to not admit that and I'm going
to counter that with we are justifiably
not let into spaces and our whiteness
takes away access to things like powwows
there's an island in Hawaii that's only
for natives or for like safe spaces for
black communities or whatever else we
are justifiably denied access because of
our skin period we love the new on the
thing about Hawaii though yeah Hawaii is
stolen land I believe that they have
every right to be able to say only we're
allowed to go here because that was
theirs it was literally stolen land that
was stolen by white people yes no but
that's why it's justifiably it's still
denied access but it is justifiable 100%
don't let in it's denied access but it's
justifiable but it's like in my own
dayto life I can go anywhere I can sit
down anywhere I can go read a book in a
library I can go to Starbucks people
don't fear me because of how I look and
so they don't feel the need to be like
you can't be here but like in in your
day-to-day life are you being denied
access like are you trying to go to that
island that they won't let you okay then
I think that's a really good question
like am like like has it happened um I
guess cuz like are you seeking those
spaces then I'm not necessarily seeking
them if I am already aware that this is
like hey this is for for us not for you
I'm not going to show up and be like
yeah but like I'm a cool white person
but there are spaces that we are not
allowed and I think that's okay no it is
okay but if you're not actively seeking
to be part of those circles you're not
being denied access to them I will agree
with that sure and I like and I can say
that maybe those are not the best
examples but like I think especially
because my Social Circles are
predominantly people of color there are
definitely things where they're like
where I've had them be like this is not
a conversation for you and I'm like okay
I have had those experiences I'm okay
with them I want to be clear like I
think there should be spaces that aren't
for me and that is okay but they've
existed and they've been in my life I
have just one really specific example
otherwise I feel like in general I'm not
denied access because of my race just in
my experience but I had an ex whose
stepfather was wildly racist like Nazi
memorabilia like just insane individual
and I was never allowed over her house
because of him and the one time that I
kind of snuck in he was staring at me
through the window and I'll never forget
that in my life the way that man was
staring at me through the window and
then cursed out his kids for having me
in the house that man's now in prison
for doing God knows what but uh it's
where he belongs I was looking for
funding for um for my film and most of
them are for colored people and I
totally understand that and there is
like not many that I found that are for
like everybody my mind would be like you
know H damn I cannot do it like I cannot
apply to it but from the other side I
understand that the black community like
you guys need to get get your movies out
there if anything I feel like I've been
invited too much you know I I I feel
like I'm kind of like a undercover agent
where I'm like like because I talk a
certain way or because I present myself
a certain way they assume like oh I
could say this in front of you and I'm
like what did you say exactly token I've
never I've never really been I'll say
that too I've been toen I so many times
we have to have you here we need young
black representation and I'm like yes
I'm going to stay home yeah I am proud
of my
race three two
one I will go first and I will stand T
toes in I was just being ironic to stand
over there
okay I said please no my I cried a
little bit that like and I'll just keep
it specific to to my experience of what
I know as black Americans we're pretty
much the top culture that gets
replicated referenced people scoot in
and Scoot out cuz they want to seem cool
and interesting and stuff and I think
that that's so kind of us to like kind
of like be beaten down for so long and
be kind of separated from our African
Roots create names for ourselves cult
culture language around our identities
as black Americans and have that be a
thing that's just reverberating across
the globe I think that's so cute can
never be replicated can never be
understated and um I love that about it
that was kind of the start of my like
thought process too like just the basis
of being torn down so adamant so
regularly for hundreds of years in law
even like it is insane that we are here
today to even be on camera to even be in
a place with other white people like it
is a beautiful thing that we have been
able to flourish in such dirt like
literal filth and grime that our
ancestors had to go through and even our
grandparents had to go through like in
my eighth grade yearbook I saw recently
said like the South will rise again like
in this was 2015 so like this is such a
day-to-day thing and I am proud to be
black and it's hard to say that like it
was hard to say that as a kid like or
else I could be called inward I could be
reprimanded and it's I feel so blessed
to even be able to think that everybody
needs needs to be proud of their race
and stop this like racist
because like you could be green red
black white hispanic like it doesn't
matter I agree with like what you're
saying because my own personal belief is
that at the basis of who we are is that
we're all just people we're not a skin
tone but because of those before me I
now have to fight back against the idea
that all white people are racist I
remember being in fourth grade and
learning about the Holocaust for the
first time and saying I don't want to be
German anymore Meanwhile my mother's
whole family is German American history
you look at things like slavery you look
at things like um Jim curl laws
segregation there is so much awful stuff
that has happened and is still happening
in closeted ways that I cannot be proud
of the way that I look yeah for me like
I am proud of who I am like who I grew
up to be like I like who I am but like
if I were to say I'm a proud white man
like I don't even know what that means
like there have been zero racial hurdles
in my life now like I'm a proud gay man
because like I've had to go through
to get to where I am now and you know
even to that point so much of queer
culture comes from Black Culture so
thank you you're
welcome I want to be proud of the things
I've done the people who I've touched
whose Hearts I've opened up I feel like
it's beyond our race I feel like what it
is is our experiences that make our
light shine through so that's what I'm
proud of actually yeah I think that
there's a really big difference between
being proud to be black and being proud
to be white so being proud of your
culture beautiful thing like be proud to
be Ukrainian I'm proud to be Slavic the
black community is different and the
reason it's different is because their
culture specifically black Americans
their culture was stripped like stripped
away from them when they were brought
over here so then the culture became
being black American your like the race
became cultural I mixed that up sorry
about but like so I think that there's a
really big difference between like I am
proud of my people My People Are Slavic
versus I am proud of my race it just
gets convoluted because black Americans
the race has become the culture because
the culture was stripped away I also
think often times when you talk about
white pride versus black pride often
times black pride is rooted in like love
and like perseverance of like culture
customs language and things like that
and white pride is often rooted in like
black hate Latin hate Asian hate so I
think that's like an interesting um
Nuance to not Overlook no and it's I
think that's such an important point I
think there's a difference between like
I'm proud and therefore I'm better
versus I am proud of what we have
overcome yeah and then the whole idea of
white pride started with people who
think the Confederate flag is
personality trait so how can I be proud
of that drag I'm not saying that this
applies to any of you but I meet a lot
of white people particularly white
liberals who will actively say that
they're ashamed of being white and that
is wild to me because how can you look
at your past and because yes you raced
terrible things in the past but you
shouldn't Define yourself as that of
anything you should look at that and
reflect so do you think white people
should be proud to be specifically white
see I think that's a really nuanced
question when you're white because I
think you guys had the valid point of
ethnicity is different cuz like white
isn't a collective culture in the way
that black is because black people been
grouped together and have a similar
experience but like white like Italian
American you should definitely be proud
of being Italian ameran you should be
proud of being Slavic American you
should be proud of your lineage but just
to say oh I'm proud to be white like
yeah that has a weird connotation to it
because it's not a collective culture
but what I really want to emphasize is
that you should not be ashamed of being
white in the way that a lot of people
are yes or maybe you
should you that one is on
you
all lives
matter white people white people